I co-signed um for my boyfriend for a
car um he owes about 32,000 or I should
say we owe about 32,000 and he's been
behind on the payment um I've been
denied for two personal loans um for the
difference of the vehicle um due to my
debt to income ratio so I'm really
trying to figure out how to get from
under this car um completely he's doing
harm to the person he claims to
love you because he can't pay the
Bill we know that cuz he hasn't been
paying the bill and it's messed up your
credit am am I missing something no no
what does he make a
year um he makes about 55 yeah, yeah so
the car was a bad purchase
anyway buying buying a $32,000 car when
you make 55 is not is out of line even
if you pay cash for it